como lo prometido es deuda volvemos para
revisar las noticias de la economía
mundial con jorge hurtado jorge un
saludo nuevamente para ustedes de
igualmente angela y vamos a iniciar
hablando otra vez del petróleo y del
comunicado que lanzaron los países
productores así es la alianza de países
productores de petróleo conocida como
opep se dio a la presión de los países
consumidores de aumentar la producción
de petróleo mundial aunque lo hicieron
con una advertencia tras meses de
solicitudes de aumentar la producción
para bajar los precios la opep anunció
que a partir de enero añadiría 400 mil
barriles diarios de crudo a los mercados
mundiales una medida que debería
complacer a grandes consumidores como
eeuu pero lópez advirtió que podrían
revisar la decisión en cualquier momento
debido a la incertidumbre del mercado
sobre todo después de la aparición de
una nueva variante de kobe 19 en abril
del año pasado en plena pandemia la opep
redujo su producción para compensar el
desplome histórico que produjo la
pandemia
la opep evitó reaccionar al desafío que
les planteó washington hace unos días
cuando anunció que liberaría más de 50
millones de barriles reservas
estratégicas en de petróleo en días
pasados un funcionario de lópez advirtió
que esos barriles adicionales pueden
causar un gran desequilibrio en el
mercado bueno hay una noticia de ires y
venires en américa latina argentina dice
que está por llegar a un acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional así es un
equipo técnico del banco central de
argentina así como algunos funcionarios
de gobierno viajarán a washington el
próximo sábado para reunirse con el
fondo monetario internacional
desde el año pasado argentina negocia
con el fm y refinanciar deudas que
rondan unos 43.300 millones de dólares
estas son derivadas de un acuerdo de
auxilio financiero que fue firmado en
2018 entre ese organismo y el entonces
el gobierno de mauricio macri argentina
debería pagar al fmi entre capital e
intereses 19 mil 20 millones de dólares
el próximo año 19 mil 270 millones de
dólares en 2023 y 4 mil 856 millones de
dólares en 2024 compromisos que el
gobierno de alberto fernández asegura no
está en condiciones de escuchemos que
dijo gabriela cerrutti y es portavoz de
la presidencia de argentina las
reuniones con el estado del fondo son
reuniones y negociaciones que se siguen
manteniendo en el marco de una
negociación se mantuvieron en roma se
siguen manteniendo para llegar y para
seguir trabajando en la búsqueda de un
acuerdo que es lo que todos esperamos
que suceda próximamente angela y es que
un funcionario de la firma moody's
consideró que tarde o temprano va a
haber una devaluación en argentina y
anticipó que el riesgo-país va a
mantenerse bastante alto si el país
logra inclusive un acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional bueno pues lo
veremos más adelante entre tanto cómo
evoluciona la economía en turquía y la
lira así que bueno la lira que es la
moneda oficial de ese país volvió a caer
en mínimos históricos luego de que el
presidente
erdogán nombrada el nuevo ministro del
tesoro y finanzas hernán nombró al
viceministro nuredín ne bati para el
puesto esto luego de la salida de lufti
gilvan durante la primera caída de la
lira la semana pasada el desplome de la
libra se produce tras una serie de
recortes en los costos de los tipos de
interés a pesar de que los precios al
consumo van en aumento y dificulta la
compra de alimentos y otros productos el
nuevo funcionario tiene un doctorado en
ciencias políticas y administración
pública es conocido por ser partidario
de la campaña de erdogán para reducir
los tipos de interés la moneda turca ha
perdido cerca del 40 por ciento de su
valor desde principios de año y ha
generado protestas en contra del
gobierno
erdogán ha destituido a tres
gobernadores del banco central desde
2019 por diferencias sobre los tipos de
interés y por favor cuáles son los
indicadores de la jornada iniciamos con
wall street que cerró con ganancia ya
que los inversores aprovecharon la caída
de precios de la sesión pasada para
comprar acciones a mejor precio las
acciones europeas cayeron más de un 1
por ciento debido a que los países
intensificaron las restricciones para
frenar la propagación de la variante del
coronavirus conocida como omi chrome y
en américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
se disparó impulsada por las ganancias
de petrobras y la cifra del día bueno la
cifra del día tiene que ver con
tecnología y con startup 1200 millones
ese es el valor de mercado de joker la
nueva startup unicornio de méxico que
busca su expansión en sudamérica
la compañía de última mía nació en marzo
de este año y se ha expandido
rápidamente en el mercado delivery o
domicilios actualmente opera en estados
unidos méxico brasil colombia perú y
recientemente angela llegó a chile muy
millonaria su cifra de hoy gracias jorge
y a nuestros televidentes de continúen
en france24 ya volvemos
[Música]